(Rires)
Ce sont des yeux mobiles.
J'ai passé 14 heures
à coudre ce T-shirt et j'ai utilisé 227 yeux mobiles.
Pouvoir vous regarder autant que vous me regardez
n'est pas la seule raison pour laquelle je l'ai fait.
Je l'ai aussi créé pour pouvoir faire ça.
(Bruit des yeux mobiles)
(Rires)
Je fais beaucoup de choses comme ça.
Je repère un problème et j'invente une sorte de solution.
Par exemple, le brossage de dents.
C'est une chose qu'on doit tous faire, mais très ennuyante.
Personne n'aime vraiment ça.
S'il y avait des enfants de sept ans dans le public,
ils crieraient tous : « Vrai ! »
Et si vous aviez un appareil qui le faisait à votre place ?
(Rires)
J'appelle ça...
J'appelle ça « Le casque brosse à dents ».
(Rires)
(Grincement du bras du robot)
(Applaudissements)
Aucun dentiste ne recommande mon casque brosse à dents
et il n'a clairement pas révolutionné le monde de l'odontologie.
Mais il a radicalement changé ma vie.
Car j'ai terminé ce casque brosse à dents il y a trois ans
et lorsque je l'ai terminé,
je suis allée dans mon salon et j'ai installé une caméra,
puis je l'ai filmé en marche pendant 7 secondes.
À présent,
je vis le conte de fées moderne
de la fille qui poste des vidéos sur le Web.
La fille fait un carton sur le Web,
des milliers d'hommes parcourent les commentaires
pour lui demander sa main.
(Rires)
Elle les ignore tous, crée une chaîne Youtube
et continue à fabriquer des robots.
Depuis, je me suis fait une place sur le Web
en tant que créatrice d'appareils inutiles,
car nous le savons tous,
le meilleur moyen de briller dans son domaine,
c'est de choisir un domaine peu développé.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Donc je tiens une chaîne Youtube où je présente mes appareils
et j'ai testé par exemple la coupe de cheveux au drone.
(Drone qui vrombit)
(Rires)
(Drone qui s'écrase)
(Drone qui vrombit)
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Un appareil qui m'aide à me réveiller le matin.
(Réveil)
(Rires)
(Vidéo) Simone : Aïe !
Un appareil qui m'aide à couper les légumes.
(Couteau qui coupe)
Je ne suis pas ingénieure.
Je n'ai pas fait d'école d’ingénieurs.
Mais, plus jeune, j'étais une élève très ambitieuse.
En primaire et au collège, j'avais des 20/20
et j'étais première de la classe.
Mais d'un autre côté,
je luttais contre de grosses angoisses liées à la performance.
Voici un email que j'ai envoyé à mon frère à cette époque.
« Tu ne sais pas combien c'est dur pour moi de te le dire,
de te l'avouer.
J'ai tellement honte.
Je ne veux pas que les gens me croient stupide.
Maintenant je mets à pleurer.
Merde. »
Non, je n'ai pas accidentellement mis le feu à la maison de nos parents.
La chose dont je parle dans cet email et qui me contrarie,
c'est d'avoir eu 15 à un contrôle de maths.
Quelque chose s'est clairement passé entre ce moment et aujourd'hui.
(Rires)
L'une de ces choses, c'est la puberté.
Magnifique époque en effet.
Mais aussi,
mon intérêt pour la construction de robots
et ma soif d'en apprendre plus sur le matériel informatique.
Construire un objet à partir de hardware, surtout en étant autodidacte,
c'est quelque chose de très difficile.
C'est quasiment l'échec assuré.
De plus,
la probabilité de se sentir stupide était très élevée.
Et c'était ma plus grande peur à l'époque.
Donc j'ai imaginé un système qui garantirait un succès à tous les coups.
Avec mon système, il est quasiment impossible d'échouer.
Au lieu de chercher à réussir,
j'allais essayer de construire des objets défectueux.
Et même si je ne le réalisais pas à l'époque,
construire des objets stupides était plutôt malin,
car en apprendre davantage sur le matériel informatique
m'a, pour la première fois,
fait oublier mes angoisses liées à la performance.
Dès que je me suis défaite de la pression et des attentes que je m'imposais,
cette pression a rapidement fait place à de l'enthousiasme
et cela m'a permis de juste jouer.
En tant que créatrice,
je m'intéresse à ce qui pose problème aux gens,
que ce soit de petits, moyens ou gros problèmes.
Et la participation à une conférence TED présente toute une série de problèmes
que je peux résoudre.
L'identification d'un problème constitue la première étape pour
construire un appareil inutile.
Avant de venir ici,
Je me suis pose et j'ai pensé aux problèmes pouvant se présenter
lors de cette conférence.
Oublier ce qu'on veut dire.
Que les gens ne rient pas -
comme vous.
Ou pire,
que vous ne rigoliez pas au bon moment.
Vous pouvez rire à ça,
merci.
(Rires)
Que mes mains tremblent à cause du stress
et que ça me gêne vraiment.
Que ma braguette soit ouverte tout le long de la conférence
que vous le remarquiez et moi non,
mais elle est fermée, donc tout va bien de ce côté.
Mais ce que j'appréhende vraiment, ce sont les mains qui tremblent.
Je me souviens quand j'étais enfant,
lorsque je faisais des exposés,
j'avais des notes sur un bout de papier
et je posais un cahier en-dessous
pour ne pas que les gens remarquent le papier qui tremble.
Et je fais beaucoup de conférences.
Je sais qu'environ la moitié d'entre vous se disent sûrement :
« Construire des choses inutiles divertit
mais comment peut-on en vivre ? »
En donnant des conférences, par exemple.
Les organisateurs placent toujours un verre d'eau sur scène
au cas où vous auriez soif.
Et j'ai tellement envie de boire cette eau à chaque fois,
mais je n'ose pas prendre ce verre
de peur que les gens s'aperçoivent que mes mains tremblent.
Alors pourquoi ne pas inventer une machine qui vous tend ce verre ?
Banco pour la fille nerveuse portant un T-shirt aux yeux mobiles.
À vrai dire, j'ai besoin de le retirer car j'ai cette chose --
(Bruit des yeux mobiles)
Oh.
(Cliquetis)
(Rires)
Je ne sais toujours pas quel nom lui donner,
mais je pensais à « appareil en orbite autour de la tête »,
car la plateforme tourne autour de vous et vous pouvez y poser n'importe quoi.
Vous pouvez poser un appareil photo et prendre des photos de votre tête à 360°.
C'est vraiment -- c'est un appareil très polyvalent.
(Rires)
Ok et j'ai --
Vous pouvez poser des collations dessus par exemple
si vous le souhaitez.
J'ai du pop-corn.
Vous en posez un peu comme ça.
Ensuite vous voulez --
il y a des sacrifices à faire pour la science --
du pop-corn qui tombe par terre.
Faisons-lui faire le tour.
(Robot qui vrombit)
(Rires)
Et puis il y a une petite main.
Vous devez ajuster sa hauteur
en haussant les épaules.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Il y a une petite main.
(Main qui claque)
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai explosé mon micro,
mais tout va bien.
Je dois manger ce pop-corn aussi,
donc si vous pouviez juste applaudir encore un peu --
(Applaudissements)
C'est un peu comme votre propre système solaire,
car je suis de la génération Y,
donc je veux que tout tourne autour de moi.
(Rires)
Revenons-en au verre d'eau, on est là pour ça.
Promis -- il contient toujours --
il n'y a plus d'eau dedans,
désolée.
Je dois encore travailler sur cet appareil,
car j'ai encore besoin de prendre le verre d'eau et de le poser,
mais si vos mains tremblent un peu,
personne ne le remarquera,
car vous portez un appareil très hypnotisant.
Donc tout va bien.
OK.
(Robot qui vrombit)
(Chant)
Mince, il est coincé.
Un robot qui peut avoir peur sur scène, n'est-ce pas réconfortant ?
Il s'est juste un peu coincé.
Très humain de sa part.
Attendez, revenons un peu en arrière,
et puis --
(Verre qui tombe)
(Rires)
N'est-ce pas une belle journée pour vivre ?
(Applaudissements)
Même si mes créations peuvent s'apparenter à de l'ingénierie déjantée,
je réalise que j'ai mis le doigt sur quelque chose de plus grand.
Ce sentiment de joie et d'humilité qui se perd parfois dans l'ingénierie.
Ça m'a permis d'en apprendre plus sur le hardware
sans être pénalisée par mes angoisses liées à la performance.
On me demande souvent si je finirais par construire quelque chose d'utile,
un jour peut-être.
Mais selon moi,
c'est déjà le cas,
car je me suis créé un emploi
et c'est quelque chose que je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer,
ou que j'aurais --
(Applaudissements)
Quelque chose que je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer.
C'est arrivé, car j'aimais ce que je faisais
et je partageais cet enthousiasme avec les autres.
Le véritable intérêt de faire des choses inutiles,
c'est de constater
que vous ne savez pas toujours quelle est la meilleure solution.
Et cette voix dans votre tête se tait,
celle qui vous dit que vous savez exactement comment le monde fonctionne.
Un casque brosse à dents ne résout peut-être rien,
mais au moins vous posez la question.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)